[Applause]
okay so one of the frustrations i had
while i was
off is that i was watching this war go
on in israel israel is the champion of
having very quick wars this one was 11
days but most of them you can count by
days even the ones where they were
facing whole armies
um and it was frustrating to me because
there was no one on liberal media to
defend israel really we've
become this country now where we're kind
of one-sided on this issue i did also
like to say off the bat that i don't
think
kids understand and when i say kids i
mean the younger generations that you
you can't learn history from instagram
there's just not enough space
so i want to go over some of the history
but first i read your column on it
even-handed and brilliant as usual
but let me just quote you off the bat
you say at home
israel has a robust democracy that gives
more rights to arab citizens than its
neighbors do
this was after
this was after all a war with gaza
thank god israel treats its arab
citizens better than egypt saw
syria or saudi arabia treat their arab
citizens i didn't see much of that in
the press
i was glad to see you say it can you put
some bones on that why
do you say they treat their citizens
better they're arab citizens
so i mean i also said a lot more
and clearly within israel then
arab citizens obviously vote they can
serve in the knesset
they can be judges the some of the most
robust organizations speaking up for
palestinians
are organizations like bethelem the
human rights organization
uh you know that does not happen in
egypt which obviously massacres
egyptians
who support democracy we've seen what
happens in syria but i would
also say that you know i made that point
for context i think it's important to
understand that
uh that israel at home truly is robust
but
you know i don't think that's a defense
for
israel uh uh engaging in possible war
crimes in gaza
uh or uh engaging well gaza fired
four thousand rockets into israel what
would you say israel should have done
instead of what they did
so how could you not submit so i mean
international lawyers are pretty clear
that they have a right to defend
themselves they have a right to respond
to
at military targets but there was a
sense that the response
uh was probably a war crime because it
did not sufficiently avoid civilian
casualties
uh but they purposely put the rockets in
civilian places
that's their yeah well likewise israel's
defense ministry is in a civilian area i
mean
both sides do this partly because
they're crowded countries i do think
that hamas
particularly does this and i think
that's a war crime in the part of hamas
and clearly hamas is engaging in war
crimes when it challenges war is a crime
i i mean it seems like a silly argument
when people go to war i mean there are
certain things that are beyond the pale
this seems like i mean it was a normal
war
people die in war it's a horrible thing
but
but i mean there we have developed laws
of war precisely to restrain the
inhumanity of war
we don't allow chemical weapons and i
don't know how else you
respond when you are for i mean what if
canada
fired 4 000 rockets into america or
mexico where which is a
even better analogy because we actually
did steal the land from mexico
uh i would submit that israel did not
steal anybody's land this is another
thing i've heard
the last couple of weeks words like
occupiers
and colonizers and apartheid which i
don't think people understand the
history there
there the jews have been in that area of
the world
since about 1200 bc
way before the first muslim or arab
walked the earth
a thousand years before i mean jerusalem
was their capital
okay so if it's just about who got there
first it's it's not even close
there have been a continuous jewish
presence yes
the jews were the ones who were occupied
by everybody the romans
took over at some point and then the
persians and the byzantines and then the
ottomans
so yes there was colonization going on
there
beginning in the 20th 19th century
they started to return to palestine
which was not never an arab country
there was never a country called
palestine that was a distinct arab
country
and yes there was a a problem there
because there was two people who wanted
to share the land which is why the u.n
in 1947 said okay we're going to
partition it
we have the map i want to show it people
forget what the map looks like
this is what was on the table at the
beginning the green is the part
that the arab population would have
gotten
it's a good part of the country it's the
good part a lot of it look what israel
has a little sliver by the coast in the
desert in the south
that second map is what israel has today
yes it is a lot more but doesn't it
behoove
the people who rejected the treat that
the half a loaf and then continue
attacked hamas charter says they just
want to wipe out israel
their negotiating position is you all
die
but i mean there's a difference between
this defending hamas
which i agree commits war crimes and i
i would accept that i think uh too often
in liberal circles there's been a
tendency to
allied the repression of hamas the
homophobia of hamas the misogyny of
hamas but that also
does not excuse israel ruling
palestinians in the west bank for
example without giving them any vote
taking water and giving it to settlers
and maybe most important
um damaging any possibility down the
road of creating a two-state solution
you know how do we avoid a war when
somebody is showing
some your neighbor is showing you that's
hard but what we can do
is try to create a two-state solution
ten years from now
and the way you do that is you don't
build up settlements right now in the
west bank
and you don't create this division where
palestinians you don't seize their homes
and shake gerard
i would agree with that and i think a
lot of israelis do too
do they not enough to elect well because
because again
i mean first of all the two-state
solution has been on the table a number
of times there could be a
arab capital in east jerusalem now if
yasser arafat had accepted that in 2003
he did not
i mean they have they have rejected this
and went to war
time and time again and
you know as far as gaza goes um it's
it's amazing to me that the progressives
think that they're being progressive by
taking
that side of it the bella hadids of the
world these
influencers um i just want to say
in february of this year a hamas court
ruled that an
unmarried woman cannot travel in gaza
without the permission of a
male guardian really
that's the that's where the progressives
are bella hadid and her friends
would run screaming to tel aviv
if they had to live in gaza for one day
right
but i mean i've been to gaza any number
of times
and ordinary gazans complained about
hamas all the time
i did not perceive bella hadid as
defending hamas
i saw her as speaking up for you know
seven kids in gaza who were killed
well she's from the river to the sea
palestinian palestine will be free
is i think what she chanted with people
that is a plo
slogan that means israel from the river
to the sea is that there will be no more
israel uh you want to say something
about this
well i was kind of glad to listen
because i feel like
do i want to step on the land mine no
not really
but just to buttress
uh next point a little bit is to
understand that they were about to form
a government
that included the arab party correct
once you're
once you're a part of the government if
you need your three votes into knesset
to get to 61.
no apartheid no apartheid state ever did
what's it
and the part that we think of as south
africa which is
the white people in britain and holland
who never had any claim to the land or
any history there
came thousands of years later and just
took it over that's a little different
and then they kept it an apartheid state
because they just wanted the power
the israelis they have made mistakes but
it's an apartheid state because they
keep getting attacked
if they don't keep a tight lid on the
they get
killed and that seems like something
different
[Applause]
for the same reason that you admire
israeli democracy
and that you admire the fact that arabs
within israel
have the vote then shouldn't those
palestinians and the west bank have a
vote for the people who ruled
against israeli arabs do have the vote
and they're in the parliament
in an apartheid okay
you